And now the old scout master.
Well, why don't you ask your patrol leader about that?
Well, ask him. ask him again.
Alright, well, ask your senior patrol leader about that.
Well, where are you supposed to be right now?
Hey, this is podcast number 152..
Welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
It's been a great year
And this is our New Year's edition of the scout master podcast, in which we're going to play some
excerpts from some of the interviews that we did over the past year. a couple of little features,
And I hope you enjoy it.
There's a lot coming in 2013..
2012 was a great year for the podcast.
I had a great year scouting
And we were able to talk to some really interesting people for the podcast,
And we're going to have some excerpts of those interviews coming up here in a moment.
But before we do that, I wanted to just talk to you about 2013..
It's a promising year
And I mentioned this in the last podcast, but I'm working together with some people to develop a monthly live event.
Put aside some time on Sunday evening, January 13th, for a launch of what we hope will become kind of a monthly virtual roundtable.
What we have coming up in January is a presentation about the BSA STEM NOVA program, which, if you're not familiar with it, it's a relatively new initiative
And it's a focus on science and technology.
Looking forward to the presenters that we've lined up, who've been very involved with the STEM NOVA program since its inception,
And I think you'll get a lot out of it.
January 13th-
It's a Sunday evening,
You know. look around seven or eight o'clock.
I'll have more exact information and links and all that business posted,
But right now we're in the middle of our holiday week.
We've got some excerpts from interviews we've done over the past year.
Let's see.
We've got Lenore Scanesi, who's the author of Free Range Kids.
Lenore's boys are in scouts
And she is a columnist and a writer who brings a very pragmatic point of view and a dose of reality to raising children,
And I really enjoyed talking to Lenore.
Next we'll have Andrew Skirka,
And Andrew is this incredible long distance backpacker who wrote the backpacking gear guide that I know that a lot of you have now. that was published by National Geographic this past year.
Mike Malone, the author of Four Percent: The History of the Eagle Scout Award, which just recently came out in a hardcover edition.
Mike and I had a great interview about the book and about being an Eagle Scout.
We'll finish up with an interview I conducted with our immediate past National Counsel Executive, Bob Mazooka, who was kind enough to join us back in the spring and talk a little bit about his journey to Eagle and his work as our National Scout Executive.
So that's a pretty full podcast, wouldn't you say.
I would say
So let's get started, shall we?
Lenore Skinezi joins us today.
She's a nationally syndicated newspaper columnist.
Lenore, welcome to the Scout Master Podcast.
Oh, very happy to be here.
I salute you, Clark.
Every parent, they're torn between the safety of their children and wanting to see them do interesting, wonderful things that help them develop and help them develop this kind of confidence.
Right, I'm saying they go together.
So it's not really a trade-off between you know, on the one hand I want them safe but on the other hand I want them to have adventures.
In a way, having these adventures in a sort of tried and true environment, which is the Scouts, makes them safer,
And having your kids do those interesting things that maybe are not perfectly safe but are still safe.
I mean, you know, you have trained scout leaders who are there and you have older kids who have learned a lot and are willing to look after the younger kids.
You know, scouting is not dropping your kids off at the side of a highway and saying go into the forest and I'll pick you up in three days.
It really is a way to train kids to become just more competent.
I love what scouting is doing for my sons.
You know, I mean it really. they have to grow up and they might not even want to sometimes.
I mean sometimes it really involves, you know, putting away the tent, which is what I hear is a total drag. or getting the little kids to, you know, clean up the litter,
which is hard to do, and it's like me cleaning up the house, like easy to just do yourself, but no, they have to get the kids to do it.
And then they come home and they're a little different,
They're just. I mean, I want them to grow up and be responsible and be proud and reverent and brave and true and all that stuff.
And weirdly enough, you know, I don't think scouts would be around for 100 years if that wasn't, you know, if there wasn't proof that that's what happens.
Andrew Skirka has won a lot of attention for his solo long distance backpacking trips
And he figures that in the last decade or so he's covered 30,000 plus miles
And that's the equivalent of traveling 1.2 times around the Earth's equator.
He's been named adventurer of the year by both outside and the National Geographic Adventure magazines, as well as Person of the Year by Backpacker Magazine.
He's also the author of the recently published Ultimate Hikers Gear Guide from National Geographic
And if you look at your March April edition of Scouting Magazine there, he is right there on the cover.
I'm happy to welcome Andrew to the Scout Master Podcast. Good morning, Andrew. How are you?
Good morning, Thanks very much for having me.
Well, no, I really appreciate you spending the time.
So you talk about the first real backpacking trip. you went on as being that you left. you set out from Springer Mountain in Georgia on the Appalachian Trail.
How did that go?
Oh, it was bad. It was bad.
So it was my first congress trip. It was my first backpacking trip,
And now I describe myself as a camper by default, which is a backpacker that takes too much, because they're basically packing their fears.
They justify a lot of gear decisions on the grounds of what if or just in case, and they just don't know.
I also shared a lot of conventional gear, which is because I just didn't know any better
And I thought that what the industry was telling me and what an REI catalog was telling me, that that was the right thing.
You go into detail about that experience and kind of the evolution that you went through as far as the selection of gear and everything, and your philosophy and your approach to these trips
in the Ultimate Hikers Gear Guide.
It's really a game changer. I think it's a great piece of work and I think it's going to make things really, really work for people.
If they'll go and look at the book and follow your advice, I think we're going to see a whole lot more successful backpackers developed out of it.
I certainly hope so. I've made a lot of mistakes and have suffered as a result because I chose the wrong stuff or I didn't have the skills to use it properly,
And I've also made some really good decisions that I've learned a lot along the way, and the book I share that
The focus is on backpackers who want to enjoy hiking my idea of writing a book.
I think you were successful in kind of helping to redefine exactly what we're doing out there and how we make it happen. well,
One of the things that I first saw about you was a YouTube video and it really made me anxious to talk to you,
And this video is when you encounter the porcupine caribou herd.
Where were you at the time?
I was up in the Yukon Arctic, so basically far north, far northwestern Canada.
So you have, like this moment- I don't know exactly how to describe this moment- a moment of enlightenment or clarity or some kind of transcendent moment.
Can you share that with us? Can you explain what happened?
Yeah, I still struggle to explain it, to be honest, but basically I've been so worn down by what I was going through
And at the time I was in the middle of a 657 mile 24 day stretch, without crossing the road and without seeing a human being,
And I was just getting beat up on a regular basis by big floods and bears and mosquitoes,
And I was just so worn down by those elements. in addition to just this larger sense of exposure and risk and self dependence,
When I came up on a porcupine migration trail corridor, which is this very visible track across the tundra, I just broke down and realized- or not realized, but felt like I was tapping into their energy
And I knew that this is a species that, for their survival, has this journey plus a year, where they migrate back and forth from their wintering grounds to their migrating grounds,
And when they're on that journey, they are just basically eating, sleeping and moving.
And for me it was the same thing, And I had this sort of connection with the caribou, where I was just one of them.
I stopped being some elevated species, I was just another animal, first in this landscape that was having the same experience: that they were looking over my shoulder.
I was trying to send myself off from those variables that I listed before.
It was a pretty amazing moment, and definitely never something that had happened before and not something that would have been possible if I hadn't really- almost only intentionally- worn myself down and just wasn't unable to keep my guard up to have that experience.
So, friend of the blog and podcast, Michael Esmalone is one of the world's best known technology writers.
Now, in this centennial year of 2012,, the centennial year of the Eagle Scout, Mike turned his considerable talent as an investigative reporter and writer, as well as his extensive experience as a scout and adult volunteer,
towards a book that no doubt will stand, at least in my humble opinion, as the definitive history of the Eagle Scout Award.
It's called 4% and subtitled The Story of Uncommon Youth in a Century of American Life.
I think it's not only an authoritative history of the award but it's kind of a meditation on the meaning and the spirit and importance of it
And I'm certainly honored to welcome to the podcast. Thanks for joining us, Mike.
Well, thank you, Clair.
So in the first chapter of the book you call the Eagle the PhD of boyhood.
Yeah, I heard that along the way somewhere a few years ago and I thought it was a brilliant metaphor for what Eagle Scouting is,
that it's a combination of learned skills combined with a final culminating event,
which is the Eagle Service Project that has to contribute to the larger world.
And if you look at it that way, it really is like a doctorate and there's nothing comparable to it in American boyhood. that never has been
And it's really the apogee of being a teenage boy in the United States
And it's been that way for 100 years now.
For long as I've been involved in Scouting- no doubt as long as you've been involved- there's always been a lot of discussions that tend to turn into arguments about what constitutes an Eagle Scout.
Yeah,
People can get pretty exercised about it. You've had an interesting perspective of that question. Is there an answer?
There's simple answers and there's complicated answers. The simple answer is being an Eagle Scouts state of mind.
One of the amazing things about the Eagle Award is it's the only award of childhood that stays with you your entire life.
You go in the military. you can wear your Eagle Medal- a special version of it-
When you're 90 years old and you die, your paper in your obituary is likely to mention the fact that you were an Eagle Scout.
It's not going to mention you were varsity football or anything else you did as a kid.
It's attached to your entire life and to be cognizant of that fact and to live up to it is to be a true Eagle Scout.
That's the simple answer. There's a more complicated answer.
You've dealt with it a lot in your blog. A lot of the people writing in commenting, especially people asking for advice. a lot of people write in and say:
You know, we decided not to let this boy become an Eagle because we don't think he's worthy.
That's that whole messy business of you know. do you fit the stereotype of an Eagle Scout?
And that one always bugs me And I think it bugs most Eagles.
I've found that people who are adults, who are Eagle Scouts, are usually a lot more flexible about Scouts becoming Eagles.
I think you don't really become an Eagle Scout when they put that medal on you.
I think it's something that you grow into over time. as I think I've written to you in the past,
Nobody gets the Eagle easy. You become an Eagle. If you earn the Eagle and you're serious about it, you become an Eagle.
You may finally become an Eagle when you're 30. You may do it when you're 15..
But if you live the Eagle life, you become an Eagle.
That's a really good way of looking at it And maybe it'll help inform people who get a little exercised about this every once in a while.
Yeah, I'm weary of that. You know we put enormous stress upon these kids,
That sort of unwritten rule that you know your Eagle project now has to change mankind forever.
That's an awful lot to put on a teenage boy. Boys are ready to do their Eagle project. when they're ready to do their Eagle project,
And not a day before, Not a minute before, Not a minute before,
A minute before, they're terrified. They don't want to do it, They don't want to deal with adults,
They don't want to organize anything And then one morning they get up and they decide I'm going to do it,
And then they're focused and they pull it off.
Was there anything in writing the book that you discovered that changed the way that you look at this at all,
Or that you just were unaware of and you thought was something pretty incredible.
I think the thing that struck me the most was that Eagle scouting stands apart from Boy Scouting.
It's one of those. it's a classic example of being, of scouting, but not necessarily part of scouting.
Once you start on the trail to Eagle beginning, when you become a life, you enter into a different reality
and you move down that path, And that path has been taken now for a hundred years by you know
what- six million, five to six million boys ahead of you,
And it's a fraternity And it's filled with like-minded people,
All of whom have decided that they're going to go for something that's bigger than anything they've ever done in their lives
And that's going to challenge them in ways they can't imagine.
And I was struck by that continuity, That Eagle scouting really is a thing unto itself
When you have this group of people that are these kind of overachievers
and who did something this big at such a young age. they're going to cut their own path for the rest of their lives,
So you can't control them. Former members who are still officially members,
who are presidents of universities and Nobel Prize winners and Medal of Honor awardees
and members of Congress- they're a heck of a lot more powerful than scouting itself
And I love that about it. And when you go to an Eagle Court of Honor
and they form the Eagle Court and inviting everybody from the audience to come up
see these guys of all ages, from their 20s to their 80s,
And you know it's colored their entire lives. Everywhere you go you're going to run into an Eagle Scout
and he's going to be the guy who's in the position of greatest responsibility.
And that's an amazing thing, It's a powerful thing.
And writing the book, I felt enormous pride in this fraternity that I was part of
and felt compelled even more to be an Eagle Scout, to act like an Eagle Scout
Music.
48 years ago, my guest was in San Juan Batista, California.
He was 16 years old and he was about to become Troop 28's newest Eagle Scout.
Now he's a pretty average scout, a pretty average, above average scout.
He spent a couple of summers on staff at Pico Blanco Scout Reservation.
He was inducted into the Esalen Lodge Order of the Arrow-
Very similar story to a lot of guys in scouting-
Went on to college and soon thereafter he started working for the Boy Scouts of America.
He continued as a scouting professional for the next 36 years
until he was selected to be our Chief Scout Executive in 2007..
And it is my great pleasure to welcome our Chief Scout Executive, Robert Mazuka,
to the Scout Master Podcast. Hello Bob,
Hello Clark, How are you?
I am just doing great
And I invited you to come and talk with us today to recognize the 100th anniversary
of the Eagle Scout Award.
And what I'm really interested in is the story of that kid back there in San Juan Batista
and Troop 28.. How'd you get started with Troop 28??
I was actually. if you've got a minute, it's kind of an interesting story.
I'm son of an Italian immigrant, one of eight kids,
And my dad was trying to figure out how to raise a family
and we moved around a little bit. in my first few years of life.
We ended up in San Juan Batista when I was eight years old
And didn't know anything about Cub Scouting.
I was never a Cub Scout but I got involved in the school and stuff.
And then my neighbor, Abraham Vega, came over one day
and he was wearing this funny uniform
And he asked me if I wanted to go with him to the Troop meeting.
I was 11 at the time, I guess,
And I went and drank the Kool-Aid and never went back.
It was really exciting.
It was one of those fun kind of things.
There was a really cool group of guys,
very eclectic group all over the map in terms of interest,
And the Scout Master was really a neat guy, Roy Pedersen,
And so I got started and got involved. a little while later
I became a Den Chief and that was my first exposure to Cub Scouting.
I didn't know what a Cub Scout was
And then I became the patrol leader of the Cobra Patrol.
The typical story was a great adventure
And it sort of kind of formed me.
It was an interesting.
I didn't know what was happening at the time
but I was sort of beginning to blossom
into things that I probably wouldn't have downheaded
and not done for Scouting.
I played football as well and baseball in high school,
But my interest in getting involved really kind of stemmed
from that invitation by a neighbor to go join a Scout Troop.
What do you remember about becoming an Eagle Scout?
that may have been a little bit different at the time than it is now.
Well, it was different. frankly,
I've been trying.
I racked my brains for years because I read
and I see all of these wonderful service projects
that are happening out there.
I couldn't remember my service project.
Maybe it's in my record- and then they reminded me
that there wasn't a service project back then.
I became an Eagle Scout.
So I'm thinking, oh God, thank you,
because I thought I would do something memorable
if I had done something.
But there was the process of the thing that I-
And I've been asked this question before-
What about the process was most beneficial to you
or most impactful on you?
And for me it was learning to be a leader.
I just did 21 merit badges.
I did the required.
I wasn't one to get all the merit badges running like that.
I was fascinated with this emerging part of me
that could be a leader
And I learned so much from that process
about servant leadership and community service
and all of that,
And I learned that it felt pretty good to be a good leader.
What do you think is the most exciting
and promising thing that's happening
in the Boy Scouts of America right now.
Well, there's a couple.
First of all, we built a major exercise
of sort of reinventing our culture.
You can change the organization chart all you want,
but changing the hearts and minds of the people in the boxes,
That's a whole other story.
Right.
And we have really sort of redefined
what we call kind of fund, the new BFA,
in ways that help us learn
how to serve our customer better,
whoever the customer happens to be,
And that's what we call the national organization.
I maintain that there's only two reasons
for the National Council to exist,
And one is to preserve and protect
and enhance the brand,
because as that brand becomes more iconic,
all the boats rise.
And the other is to help a local council
be successful, because all scouting is local.
You know, the 1325 Walnut Hill Lane,
the National Headquarters of the Boy Scouts,
owns one unit.
It's a venture crew for employees.
That's it.
Scouting happens in Peoria
and it's square and places like that.
So kind of reinventing that.
and then this whole notion of learning
how to embrace the world we live in today
with technology and the STEM initiative
and the healthy living initiative,
which are addressing national crises
that we have today with regard to science
and technology and with regard to children's health.
Those are things that I'm really proud of.
And then the iconic sort of cherry on the Sunday
is the summit project in West Virginia,
which is sort of the boldest thing
that we could do to proclaim
that we're going to be around for another 100 years-
Very intentional about talking about the future
rather than the past.
And what do you think that second century
is going to look like?
Well, I can ask a lot of you:
what are you going to look like 100 years from now?
Frankly, I don't have a clue. when you think about it,
We may be teleporting around.
We don't even know what transportation is.
But I will tell you this-
and I say this to anybody who cares to listen-
that as long as trustworthy, loyal,
helpful, friendly, courteous, kind, obedient,
clean and reverent and concepts like
on my honor, I'll do my duty,
honor and duty and God and country,
as long as those concepts are relevant,
then scouting will be relevant
and be strong 100 years from now.
But if those concepts are no longer relevant,
we're all in trouble for bigger reasons
than just scouting.
That's true.
I really believe that as long as we continue
to adapt to the world around us
in ways of delivering to the kids around us,
at whatever point in time we are.
we will continue to be successful
as long as we maintain our roots, our core values.
The contribution we've made to America
for 100 years is producing
individual good citizens
And we will always need
individual good citizens.
So you know, I can't even dream
at the rate of technology
and other things going today.
I can't even dream that we're going to work
10 years from now.
But the point is that those bedrock values
that we've stood forever
for and have stood the test of time
had better always be important
than if, as long as they're important,
we'll continue to deliver.
Well, thank you once again
for listening to this edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast
And thank you for joining us over the past year.
Remember that this is all about
a conversation.
Get in touch,
Let me know what you're up to,
Send me your questions, your comments.
I do want to make sure
to emphasize my heartfelt thanks
to everyone who does get in touch
through email or on the blog
or comments on one of the
social media outlets. there,
You know, it means so much
And it builds this virtual community of people
who are dedicated to scouting
literally all over the world-
Certainly all over the United States,
but also all over the world.
I don't want the year to go by
without thanking Larry Geiger,
Tom Gillard and Walter Underwood,
who joined me every month
for the Scoutmaster panel discussion.
That's also been great fun.
I certainly do appreciate those guys
and the time that they put in to make
in the podcast and the blog successful.
Thank you, fellas.
And being in touch is pretty easy.
All you need to do is go to the home
of the blog and the podcast,
scoutmastercgcom,
And while you're there, you can join others
who have subscribed to receive updates
to the blog and podcast by email.
You can subscribe to the podcast
on iTunes and you can also
access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
Go to stitchercom
to find out all the details on how to do that.
Hey, we're out there on the
vast panorama of social media outlets.
You can follow us at
scoutmasterblog on Facebook,
tweet scoutmastercg on Twitter,
And we have a scoutmastercg
circle on Google Plus.
And if all else fails,
I've got an email address.
How about that?
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet?
So do take the time and get in touch.
Let me know what you've been doing
regarding this past year and let me know
what you're looking forward to in the next.
The scoutmaster blog and the
scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America. No, it's just me.
I've got a microphone
and a little spare time
And we try to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
So before we leave you
this podcast and for this year,
let's hear from
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir. Until next time
and a happy new year.